When multiple denoises are available in your project,
Unreal uses console variables to decide which one path tracer relies on.
You can use r.pathTracing.spatialDenoiser.type
and toggle between spatial, zero, and temporal, one denoising.
You can use r.pathTracing.denoiser.name
to pick the spatial denoiser you prefer.
So for example, NNE denoiser, the default, or OIDN.
For temporal denoising, use r.pathTracing.temporaldenoiser.name
to choose between the options like NFOR, which is the default,
NNE denoiser, or OptiX.
These tips simply give you finer control over which denoising method is applied,
helping you balance speed, stability, and image quality.
Here are some additional CVars for targeting your final image quality.
Note, if you ever change a CVar's value and are unsure of the original default,
you can type the CVar into Unreal's command line
and hover over the text to see a tooltip
which should also show the original default value for that particular CVar.
Path Tracer now includes initial support for rendering heterogeneous volumes,
things like smoke, fire, and clouds.
You can create these volumes using the Niagara Fluids plugin
or by adding a heterogeneous volume actor directly in your scene.
These actors use sparse volume textures, for example, VDB files,
which can be imported and rendered natively in Path Tracer.
This means complex volumetric effects like simulated smoke plumes,
rolling clouds, can now be rendered with full path trace lighting and shadows.
As of the latest update, Path Tracer supports both static
and moving heterogeneous volumes,
giving artists far more greater flexibility for cinematic and visual effect work.
Now, before you dive too deep into path tracing,
keep in mind a few limitations.
First, heterogeneous volumes are only partially supported.
This includes effects like smoke and fire.
The sky atmosphere system isn't yet fully compatible with this feature,
so the results may vary depending on your scene setup.
Next, with Motion Blur, for the most accurate Motion Blur,
use the Movie Render Queue and enable Reference Motion Blur in the Path Tracing module.
This will give you a smoother, more physically accurate result,
though at a higher performance cost per frame.
In this mode, no post-processing vector blur is used.
Denoising happens after all spatial and temporal samples are accumulated.
So, for the best result, apply a higher temporal samples
and be mindful of the tick rate limitations when working with Sequencer.
And lastly, volumetric clouds are also only partially supported.
They can be captured through the skylight or represented natively
when referencing atmosphere mode is enabled in the post-processing settings.